y en éste efectivamente hay una
percepción aquí en eeuu de que el
interés friday ha perdido significado
que no se van a conseguir cuentos en que
es mucho más difícil conseguir en
cualquier producto y efectivamente el
presidente bailes ha ordenado una
inversión masiva en milán porque la
mejora de puertos y otras tengo los
elementos críticos de la infraestructura
de eeuu para ver si se recupera un poco
la fluidez en el grupo de mercancías
pero recordemos que el problema
estructural lo que está por debajo de
todo esto es que no sólo esa pandemia es
un hecho de que los eeuu están
importando destina cuatro veces más de
lo que ellos exportan a china es decir
hay un truco de barcos con por tenedores
desde asia a cientos estados unidos el
pueblo es estilo y entonces es muy
difícil equilibrar el flujo de
contenedores entre asia y eeuu de hecho
no sé realmente tuvo solución ante este
problema y los mejores cerebros de la
ingeniería están tratando de darle una
vuelta para que logremos lo que vivimos
los eeuu volver a tener las mercancías a
descuento que teníamos en años que
tuvimos en años anteriores
eso pasa también federico por la crisis
como usted lo decía que estamos viendo
en la cadena de suministros a nivel
mundial y sobre todo en eeuu porque se
generó esta crisis en la cadena de
suministros por la alta demanda de los
consumidores después de la pandemia que
otras que otros factores están detrás de
esto
desde la demanda durante la pandemia es
el controversial nunca del atún porque
los eeuu le pusieron dinero en
reconocidos consumidores aunque no
estuvieran en su casa durante toda la
pandemia y entonces la gente compró por
internet
muchísimas cosas que mantuvieron la
economía moviéndose
entonces qué pasa ya había podría grande
mangas durante la pandemia y ahora que
está la economía recuperándose la
cantidad de solicitudes de desempleo
subsidio de desempleo bajo empapado red
histórico porque el gen ya está
trabajando entonces ahora hay una sobre
demanda
lo que quiero que se entienda es que
estados unidos jamás permitió que sus
ciudadanos estuvieran en situación de
pobreza o de carencia o de penuria
durante la pandemia aunque no tuviesen
trabajo y les puso dinero
en el bolsillo directamente a cada
americano que tuviera necesidad el
gobierno federal le mandaba efe por eso
es que mucha gente desde el partido
republicano dice que ahora es difícil
conseguir trabajadores etcétera y lo
atribuyen a la largueza del gobierno
federal que mantuvo el consumo
moviéndose durante la pandemia
y de 5 viene un cambio profundo dentro
de la estructura económica
norteamericana y una parte de la
manufactura se va a mover otra vez a los
estados unidos y le voy a decir porque
no soy el gran fabricante de teléfonos y
dio dos tipos televisores cosas de ese
tipo en está confiando una inversión de
17.000 millones de dólares en texas para
fabricar electrónica
es decir que de alguna forma pasó ya
anticipa que viene un reacomodo de las
manufacturas desde la chs ya seis de los
eeuu
ahora también federico le quiero
preguntar cómo estamos consumiendo en
nuestras sociedades es un realmente un
consumo sostenible le hablo de cara
también a lo que fue la cob 26 la cop 26
en claro donde eeuu lo tomó un gran
protagonismo pero le quiero preguntar
entonces cómo estamos consumiendo es
realmente es sostenible con el medio
ambiente cómo va a cambiar el consumo de
aquí a varios años para poder salvar el
planeta que también es algo que nos
concierne a todos
pero eso es una gran cifra movimiento en
el mundo que sostiene que el consumo es
insostenible que la naturaleza se esté
en santa cuando sobre con solo estamos
consumiendo de por el planeta
directamente ya estamos en el pero la
historia de elecciones millar de esa
teoría es muy vieja
malthusiana y la economía ha probado que
falsa y efectivamente cada generación
respeta sus resortes económicos su forma
de producir y expande el horizonte de la
producción el horizonte del consumo y el
planeta
seguramente bueno aunque hay elementos
que implican que pudiéramos estar
llegando a una pequeña crisis yo confío
en que la tecnología nos va a sacar de
este atolladero para ponernos en el
próximo autor ial es decir nosotros los
seres humanos vamos a cambiar la forma
de producir la forma más eficiente por
ejemplo estamos cambiando a coches
eléctricos en estados unidos ya se viene
un
ganador
para los coches eléctricos que permitirá
que los 15 años el 80% del parque
automotor no use combustible saucito si
eso es un cambio fundamental que va a
limpiar el aire de la ciudad como nueva
york los ángeles las grandes metrópolis
súbitamente en un periodo muy pequeño
vamos a tener el caso de ciudad de texas
con una pista no se notaría que era
posible hacer de xavi
entonces yo invito a la gente hacia el
optimismo
que no vayan en ninguna carta profeco
van y vamos a mejorar el pp vamos a
vivir mejor más limpio o más ecología y
sin embargo el costo sin papel no
teniendo nos quedamos entonces con ese
optimismo federico gracias por hablar un
poco de lo que es este black friday de
eeuu y también en el resto del mundo
porque también recordemos que muchos
países lo celebran gracias federico por
su tiempo un feliz celeste o día